et regardez hatem ben arfa c'est dans la
grande rade 80 et on dirait que c'est
parti les chiffres laissent un regard un
chiffre montre est vite fait j'ai un
graphiste qui m'a fait ça comme ça tout
le monde que c'est le refus de l'argent
no money no money pour moi quoi tu vois
je t'explique et je sais ce que ça fait
exception ixtools je me disais comme
quoi il ya une rumeur qui la jugent
bonne moyenne
le deuxième axe est déjà réglé c'est
maintenant c'est où tu vas jouer
key en fait je voulais dire c'est des
joueurs je trouvais à l'époque a battu
mamie salle est ce que je voulais dire
c'est qu'aujourd'hui il faut tailler à
l'opposé du psg c'est-à-dire pêché ça
pue le fric et moi j'ai envie quand je
dis je suis ben arfa le joueur kratos si
je veux aller dans un club il correspond
à cette philosophie un club plus modeste
et ben tu vas aller à guingamp et c'est
déjà en cours
comment c'est à dire comment on peut en
fait c'est bertrand desplat c'est loupé
c'est le président de guingamp
ouais je vais dès qu'on travaille
ensemble depuis deux trois semaines et
qu'en fait je me jetais pris sous mon
aile école je vais faire venir a
également dit que j'allais venir
je n'ai eu aucun contact avec moi j'ai
pris les devants en fait est là elle
conçoit des textos comme moi parce qu'en
fait je lui ai dit et je savais qu'on se
voyait aujourd'hui c'était juste pour
conduite du temps et que je te sors de
ce merdier
là je conçois détection avec les actions
ici même voix et enfin si l'on prend
monument reste dans l'attenté
et là tu me dis ça reste un truc est
déjà parti j'ai déjà commencé à en
parler aux journalistes
mais questionné il tombe dessus en fait
j'ai des contacts j'ai parlé à un moment
où bertrand maintenant je te lancer dans
le truc dont c'est trop tard pour faire
marche arrière
quoi qu'elle marchait et même pas il ya
une marche avant en fait aujourd'hui si
tu signe là-bas moi je pense en 1971
oui mais qui sait je vais appeler je
vais appeler moment
[Musique]
ça plaît
fait mais c'est un film sur un même des
films
ouais excuse moi là je suis en compagnie
de hatem
je suis atteinte au resto avec lui ça tu
as commencé à annoncer toi ou pas parce
que il commence à recevoir des textos là
non il n'ya pas la signature mais tu
vois par rapport aux 4 non pas sans me
le passer c'est parce en ligne c + 0 moi
je te disais c'est le jour à gratot
c'était peu salace de communication pour
ça buzz attends je te le passé en face
de moi je te passe au dessus
j'aime manon 6 1 6 0
c'est flou c'est ensemble que
donc là je viens d'apprendre la nouvelle
je vais me bertrand bertrand
on passe pas par l'agent non non je sais
il est ok ok non ya pas toujours par
l'elysée qui achètent
non c'est bon je te dis que c'est bon il
a dit ok c'est bon c'est je vais lui en
parler j'ai raisonné de seconde il un
peu caractériel magie le hockey à tout
je pousserai bases un peu plus de second
semestre
à pita ces normes oui
jeanne en 2000 et à l'antenne c'est
clément gastrique infosport est ce que
c'est de mettre la télé si on veut que
tu dois vraiment mal que tu comprends ce
qui est en train de se passer
ça fait deux semaines que je parle avec
lui est ce que tu veux sincèrement
est-ce que tu penses vraiment que versa
mais que j'ai occupés chaque fois j'ai
mis une rencontre avec bertrand mon
hockey en fait ce qui va se passer c'est
que ça va aller très vite à partir de
maintenant
maintenant si l'on commencé mais c'est
un poste que je vous interromps car
c'est une information importante que je
viens de recevoir l'instant par les crs
d'une source assez proche d'hatem ben
arfa est manifestement bien informées
jeux steam indique que hatem ben arfa
serait sur le point de signer à l'en
avant guingamp
mickaël madar benarfa l'en-avant
guingamp ce sera la formation de la
journée c'est un choix qui paraît
surprenante surprenant de voir signer à
guingamp après avoir été sollicité par
des grands clubs il ya deux semaines se
relancer il a besoin de se relancer
je crois que journée le barça non qu'ils
devaient prier mais le barça n'a eu en
juin pour que c'est un peu un peu
difficile à comprendre
un jour je ferai ça vous surprend
l'écoulement non parce que je pense que
d'abord la clairière hasard
il allait en arrière donc la plèbe qui
s'appelle en avant pour lui à mon avis
ça peut être que que bien ensuite c'est
un club familial j'ai envie d'y renoncer
ses coffres il faut jouer pour le
relancer mais on apprend des places
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous en
direct sur infosport + président vous
avez conscience que si hatem benarfa
rejoint guingamp puisqu'on en parle là
sur infosport + ce serait probablement
le plus gros coup de l'histoire de votre
code
surtout qu'il accepterait la diminution
des salaires des cadres de l'équipe
demain tu fais tes valises ont par
ailleurs dans tous les trois ans et par
axa signe on envoie je suis ben arfa
logement gratos ça ça va redorer son
image
ça fait deux mois le numéro du présent
de plg je l'appelais tôt sur écoute
pas de passe et numéros je prévenir pour
moi tu penses vraiment iv signés la
mettais annoncèrent est annoncée dans
les médias je te sauve ton avenir je te
sauve ton avenir
c'est exceptionnel et sectionné excusez
moi je peux vous demander votre
attention s'il vous plaît juste que tout
le monde chante guingamp avec moi on y
va pour l'arrivée de atem garang ans
[Applaudissements]
je
les vagues exceptionnelles monde high
tech sélectionnés
[Applaudissements]